here's a little weekday motivation from
someone who inspires us
hi drew this is rachel montez miner i'm
an actress dancer and singer and now i'm
the author of the children's book the
sun the moon and the stars and i can't
wait to share it with all of you i had a
deep meditation practice and when i
became pregnant with my daughter
i had a dream
and i saw the cover of this book with
the title in the middle and children
sitting around it in a circle
and then all of the words of the book
just were downloaded to me it's
unconventional and 12 books to me came
that way during my pregnancy i do
believe because i spend so much time in
nature and meditate a lot that you know
that's how the book kind of chose me i
think
if we create space in our life through
taking a deep breath getting out in
nature taking a walk deciding to look up
at the
the sun and the trees and the clouds and
take a break from looking down at your
phone allowing some time that is
uncontrolled even if it's just a
daydream
that's when we can get our inspiration
we can let magic in our lives thank you
for sharing that with us
[Music]